STEPHANIE WONG: Now,
it's quite clear
that you won't migrate
your entire on-prem
to the cloud in the first go.
It makes a lot more
sense to migrate portions
at a time where appropriate.
As such, you'll still need a
way for your on-prem systems
to communicate with your
newly minted cloud resource.
In this episode,
I'm going to dive
into Google Cloud
Interconnect so you can set up
high-speed direct connection
to Google's network for faster
data migration and an
optimal hybrid environment.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Sure, you can reach
your cloud resources
with the appropriate VPC
firewalls and IPs in place.
But if your hybrid architecture
requires connections
with higher availability
and lower latency,
then a direct connection
to Google's network
can offer more reliability
and performance.
So let's look at how this
plays out in reality.
Black Friday is
coming up and you're
expecting a significant
spike in compute resources
to support the inbound
traffic to your site.
Now, if you have your
compute in a GCP-VPC
then you could directly ping
them from your on-prem system.
This would work, technically.
You'd get scalable
systems in the cloud
and secure processing on prem.
On the backside, however,
there are a load of issues.
Firstly, this forces the
communication between your VPC
and on-prem to go through
the public internet,
communicating through publicly
visible IPs, most likely
requiring you to secure
your traffic via a VPN
in the middle.
Secondly, this produces
a significant performance
challenge.
The public internet is
not the most performant,
and the extra overhead
of VPN on the packets
could lead to less than
desired performance
on a significant
shopping holiday.
What you want instead
is a reliable way
to connect your
on-premise workloads
to the public cloud in a secure,
fast, and reliable manner.
In other words,
you want to extend
your on-premise private
network into Google
Cloud over a dedicated link.
The purpose of Google
Cloud Interconnect
is to provide direct
fast connection
between your on-premise
and Google Cloud networks
in a secure fashion.
This security and performance
mixture is hyper-important
for a large number of industries
who work between on-prem
and in cloud--
for example, data migration,
replication, disaster recovery,
or other high-performance
computing situations.
In these scenarios, you want
to directly connect your cloud
systems while extending
your private on-prem network
to the cloud.
Google Cloud Interconnect
provides a few options that
can suit your specific needs.
But the one I'll focus on
is Dedicated Interconnect,
which provides direct
physical connections
between your on-premise
network and Google's network.
It works like this.
You set up a cross connect
between your own router
and the Google network at a
common co-location facility.
If you can't perform this,
then the official docs
have some options for you.
A BGP session is configured
over the interconnect
between the Cloud router
and your on-premise router.
BGP is a protocol that
helps route traffic
to subnets using the shortest
paths between edge routers.
Traffic from your
on-premise network
can reach your Google
Cloud VPC and vice versa.
With Dedicated Interconnect,
the immediate benefit
is an enterprise
grade connection
to your Google VPC with a
dedicated 10-gigabit per second
circuit directly to
a Google location.
Moreover, you now
have connectivity
reaching beyond Google's
existing network locations,
allowing you to scale
connectivity and save
on your egress traffic
costs from your VPC network
to your on-premise network.
Now you have a way to
transfer large amounts of data
between networks,
which can be more
cost effective than purchasing
additional bandwidth
over the public internet.
On top of that,
you'll experience
fewer disruptions and drops with
a predictable user experience.
Traffic between your
on-premise and VPC networks
doesn't touch the
public internet,
meaning fewer hops and potential
points of failure, where
it can be disrupted or dropped.
A key benefit is that your
VPC's internal IP addresses
can be directly accessed
from your on-premise network
with peering.
No net device or
VPN tunnel required.
Now let's dive into how to
actually get that set up.
First, let's make sure
you have a VPC set up
for your cloud environment.
If you haven't set that up,
see the previous episode.
Now, the first steps in
using Cloud Interconnect
involve deciding if you want
to use a dedicated connection
or a partner connection.
While there are few
nuances between the two,
depending on your
needs, the primary ones
that I'm concerned
with are speed.
Dedicated Interconnect
is ideal for situations
where you need more than
a 10-gigabit connection.
A Partner can be used
for lower speed needs.
Access-- if your
on-prem can't physically
meet Google's network in
a co-location facility,
then you can use
Partner Interconnect.
Now, for the sake
of our demo, we're
going to use
Dedicated Interconnect
because it's a little
simpler and can be cheaper
in some situations.
Let's see what this looks like.
Go to the Cloud Interconnect
Physical Connections tab
in the Google Cloud
Platform console.
Select Setup Connection.
Select Dedicated Interconnect,
and then select Continue.
Now select Order new
Dedicated Interconnect,
and then select Continue.
Specify the details for your
name, location, and capacity
of the interconnect.
Now, capacity is an
interesting metric.
The capacity you
need is determined
by the number of 10-gigabit
per second connections you can
order, also called a circuit.
Now select Next.
We'll skip over the redundancy
information for now.
But if you need that,
please see the docs
linked in the description below.
Specify your contact information
and review your order.
Now select Place Order.
On the Order Confirmation
page, review the next steps,
and then select Done.
Now, it's important to note
that you are in fact ordering
a dedicated interconnect
connection from your
on prem to Google itself.
Once Google's done
allocating things,
it will send you a
confirmation email,
and send you some
LOA-CFAs, which
you'll send to your vendor.
They will provision the cross
connects between the Google
Peering Edge and you're
on-premises network.
Now, once this is
all set up, Google
has to test your
access extensively
before you'll be able to use
the Interconnect directly.
There are some complicated
steps involved with this that
are specific to your setup.
So we'll point you to
the resource linked
in the description below
to do that, and skip it
for this video.
Once all that is
done, your final step
is to configure your
VLAN attachments.
Once Google verifies you
have a cross connect,
you see that your interconnect
is ready to configure.
And you can click Finish Setup,
and select Add VLAN Attachment.
Give it a name--
My Attachment-- and
select or create
a cloud router to associate
with this attachment.
It has to be in the VPC network
that you want to connect to.
After you're done adding
the VLAN attachments,
select Create.
The attachment takes a
few moments to create.
Now you can click Configure to
add a BGP session to your cloud
router's interface.
You give it a name
for the BGP session,
the public or private ASN of
your on-premises router, which
uniquely identifies each
network on the internet for BGP
sessions, and an optional
advertised route priority.
The Cloud router and
on-premises BGP-IP addresses
are already allocated
by the VLAN attachment.
The BGP sessions are inactive
until you configure a BGP
on your on-premises router.
If you're building redundancy
with a duplicate interconnect,
repeat these steps for
the second interconnect.
And specify a
different Cloud router.
For more info, check
out the documentation.
Now, I want to note there
are few nuances between how
you use Cloud VPN,
VPC, and Dedicated
Interconnect with your own VPN.
But that's all covered quite
well in the official doc,
so again, I'll direct you
there in the description.
Now that you have configured
a dedicated connection
to Google's network,
the next step
is to protect your
cloud instances
by configuring firewall rules.
If you want to learn
how to do that,
then stay tuned for the next
episode of "Google Cloud
Networking End-to-End."
And remember,
optimizing your network
means freeing up your bandwidth.
[MUSIC PLAYING]